[Musique]
eloi ben moi alors moi je peux chialer
là je veux moi ça a changé ma vie sorti
ça a changé ma vie j'ai trouvé des
moules et je vous fasse 5 secondes et
demie beaucoup des comme ça ça dépend ça
détend ça a changé c'est et a tout
changé j'ai trouvé une famille bon ça on
le sait j'ai trouvé un ami un papa très
fins et voilà j'ai rencontré un bon papa
papa papa pingouin et j'ai découvert un
métier que je pensais pas vouloir faire
que j'ai envie excusez-moi l'aller c'est
alors que j'ai à vous enlever tous les
micros des autres chroniqueurs les
chéris s'il vous plaît merci parce qu'on
les entend ouvrir sinon il faut pas
parler du tout voilà donne bon voilà
donc j'ai découvert un métier qui n'est
pas facile parce qu'elle chroniqueurs on
suce pas en quoi c'est pas facile moi
j'ai jamais personne était un peu
particulière très clivante
donc c'est vrai que ça a aussi apporté
beaucoup de problèmes mais non excusez
moi je dis la vérité mais
la dose de bonheur elle est dingue et
surtout j'ai rencontré ces gens ces gens
qui font de cette émission alors moi je
ne connais pas
[Applaudissements]